European Union foreign ministers have
welcomed the landmark agreement reached
between Serbia and Kosovo which could
pave the way toward EU membership at the
General Affairs Council in Luxembourg
The ministers received reports on the
two countries from the European
Commission just as it recommended that
Serbia be allowed to begin EU membership
talks and Kosovo started stabilisation
and association agreement process there
was a very strong sense that last
Friday's agreement was indeed historic
was a game-changer was a very positive
day for both Serbia and Kosovo and very
many tributes were paid to the two prime
ministers for the political courage that
they showed and reaching that agreement
Friday's agreements or Serbia
relinquished control over the northern
part of Kosovo where tensions of run
high between ethnic Serbs and the ethnic
Albanian majority in Kosovo Serbia still
refuses to recognize the independence of
Kosovo which unilaterally broke away
with Western support in 2008 some
ministers warned of the challenges ahead
in implementing the agreement
implementation will not be entirely see
but i think the Rubicon has been passed
there is no way back so wide wheel
struggled with the details of the
implementation for quite some time to
come the Rubicon has been paused during
their meeting the ministers were also
informed about the state of negotiations
over the e u--'s 2014-2020 budget with
the european parliament and asked for
their guidance on the road ahead the
Irish presidency expressed hope that a
deal will be clinched in time for the
new budget programs to begin in January